I was working at a nonprofit called
generation when I met Jasmine jasmine
was only twenty four years old but she
had already been through a lot and life
kept throwing her curveball after
curveball she had held a few jobs off
and on but most were part-time and it
was hard to manage her work schedule
with caring for her one-year-old
daughter she was living with her
daughter's father for a while so that
provided some stability but
unfortunately he developed an alcohol
abuse problem and she began to fear for
her own safety and her daughter's Jazmin
found a community in Atlanta that
provides a safe haven for women who have
escaped abusive situations with the
solid footing of Housing and Safety she
began to look for full-time work
determined to create a better world for
her daughter one that hold the promise
of opportunity that she never had
Jasmine's determination was admirable
she applied to multiple jobs every day
but received interviews from very few
employers the interview she had they
were going so well either
she knew someone had to be hiring but
despite her best efforts no one wanted
to hire Jasmine this story is not
uncommon what I found from my work at
Generation is that while the details may
change similar circumstances are
experienced by many unemployed young
people
now when I say unemployed young people I
mean those aged 18 to 29 who are not in
school and are actively searching for
work the International Labor
Organization estimates that around the
world 75 million young people are
unemployed three times as many are
underemployed this represents not just a
source of individual despair but also a
source of social unrest
as well as a gigantic pool of untapped
talent paradoxically this is a two-sided
problem according to a global report by
McKinsey & Company 40% of employers say
that a skill shortage is driving
entry-level vacancies meaning employers
cannot find the skills that they need in
the labor pool this problem has
persisted for years but it is only now
beginning to be addressed the solution I
propose modeled on this issue is to
create partnerships between the
nonprofit and for-profit worlds that
from the outset align outcomes and
enable stronger collaboration
I believe this proposition is valuable
in many sectors but for the purpose of
illustration let's consider this issue
of unemployment among young people there
are three critical aspects of the
education to employment journey first
enrolment are enough young people being
trained for the job market to building
skills is training giving young people
the right skills and 3 finding a job can
young job seekers find open positions so
why does it not work for nonprofits to
solve this issue alone a nonprofit that
focuses on skills training has many
priorities with limited time and
resources attending to this entire
education to employment journey is
nearly impossible and there are
outstanding questions on all three of
these aspects first enrollment the
nonprofit sector is highly fragmented
and with a donation-based business model
nonprofits cannot operate at this scale
needed to serve all of the young people
who would benefit from their services to
building skills without employer
involvement there is no mechanism to
ensure that the curriculum and delivery
is done in a way that prepares young
people to be successful on the job not
just in the classroom and third finding
a job without commitments from or at
least connections
with employers nonprofits may not be
helping young people with the critical
piece of actually landing a job so now
let's shift gears and consider the other
side of the coin the for-profit world in
this case that means employers why do
employers not solve this issue alone why
don't they just hire young people and
then train them the problem is it's
expensive the employer would have to
invest in developing the right type of
skills training and then when they hire
employees these employees spend a long
time being trained and during that time
they're not producing output for the
company some large employers do have the
capacity to develop training programs
but the reality is most unemployed young
people aren't going to be working for
these resource-rich large companies
additionally many unemployed young
people come from difficult life
situations similar to Jasmine they need
social support structures in place to
help them succeed in their training and
in their transition to the workplace and
this is why nonprofits are also needed
as part of the equation to address the
social issues of unemployment not just
the talent development piece and which
employers are invested in 2015
generation where I worked was launched
to bring together the nonprofit and
for-profit worlds to solve this issue of
unemployment among young people when
Jasmine went through the generation
program she benefitted tremendously from
this model as a non profit generation
was able to provide social support
services such as a mentor and a stipend
to help her cover her transportation and
food cost the program's emphasis on
employer involvement was also key to
Jasmine's success for instance
Generation had worked directly with
employers from the beginning to identify
the key skills and mindsets they needed
and this was the foundation for
Jasmine's training generation has
focused on proving the positive return
on investment of the program as this
return on investment is proven
generations funding sources have become
diverse and include government's
foundations and employers themselves all
stakeholders benefit from this
collaboration governments reduce their
unemployment rates foundations provide
economic mobility for young people and
employers have a pipeline of talent with
reduced turnover and higher productivity
this collaboration is essential to reach
the scale needed to truly move the
needle on unemployment among young
people when Jasmine graduated from the
generation program she received the job
of her dreams she called me and said
something to the effect of I feel like
my life has changed already I want my
daughter when she's grown to look back
and be proud of the life we made I think
that's possible now the program worked
for Jasmine the program has worked for
over 25,000 young people in ninety nine
cities across nine countries and it's
expanding rapidly I had the opportunity
to help launch the generation Hong Kong
program in spring 2018 right before
coming to Stanford here's a photo of
their first graduation ceremony the
program is impactful and scalable and
this would not be possible without the
collaboration among sectors in each
generation location today
I've told you a story about unemployment
among young adults because it's an issue
that matters deeply to me but I'm also
excited to be sharing my story with you
because I want to extend an invitation I
invite you to think about an issue that
matters deeply to you it could be
malnutrition financial insecurity access
to health care or any other issue that
moves you what would be possible if
nonprofit and for-profit organizations
worked hand in hand every
step of the way like they've done for
jasmine and like they've done for
thousands of other unemployed young
people around the world I challenge you
to extend this model to the issue that
matters to you because there are so many
more people in our communities and
around the world that we can help thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]